a 16 year old pregnant girl in florida
will not be able to get an abortion
because a court has decided that she is
not sufficiently mature enough to decide
for herself whether it's the right
decision to carry the fetus to term or
to get an abortion this is absolute
madness the girl's name is not being
provided as she is under 18 and they
want to protect her identity but florida
has a new 15-week abortion ban the
constitutionality of which is being
questioned but it's staying in place for
now at least the state brought that
threshold down from the 24 weeks back
a couple months ago and there is a state
law in florida that requires minors to
get parental consent for an abortion
which i would argue should not be
necessary because
even though you're a minor it's still
your body after all it's still going to
be a decision that involves you for the
next 18 years plus so it seems like they
only have this rule in place as a way to
embarrass the girl who becomes pregnant
to have to have her go to her parents
and explain the situation that she's in
and try to get their approval but as it
pertains to this story the girl in
question could not get her parental
consent because she is parentless and
she lives with a relative and has an
appointed guardian but that wasn't good
enough for a circuit court judge who
denied the parental consent waiver and a
three-judge panel upheld the decision a
statement from the appeals court said
the appellant had not established by
clear and convincing evidence that she
was sufficiently mature to decide
whether to terminate her pregnancy so
per the state of florida the girl is not
mature enough to decide whether an
abortion makes sense for her yet she is
somehow mature enough to carry a baby to
term give birth and raise it to
adulthood how does that make any sense
at all
something tells me that being a parent
requires a lot more maturity than
deciding whether a medical procedure for
someone in your position makes sense for
you so this is just the latest example
of republican barbarity on the topic
like in the lead up to roe versus wade
getting overturned when we could kind of
see the writing on the wall because of
trump's supreme court justices and then
when the draft opinion was leaked and
then when it was made official back in
june all along the right wing assured
the rest of the country that they were
going to be responsible on this abortion
issue if roe got overturned that they
would not be completely draconian and
how they addressed the matter
and they would say things like oh we'll
have exceptions for rape well now that's
being put into question because they
realized how logistically challenging
that would be because it could easily
lead to an increase in false rape
accusations then they'd say things like
oh well there'll be exceptions for life
of the mother when the life the mother
is put at risk you'll be able to get an
abortion in that instance but now
they're realizing that you can't always
assess risk levels in this way where
it's like a hundred percent that the
mother's going to survive if she has the
child or 100 chance that she's going to
die if she has a child like usually it's
in this gray area where you don't know
with any certainty what's going to
happen so who's going to decide whether
or not you fit under that exception for
life of the mother and they also used to
say oh well if roe vs wade gets
overturned then you're going to be able
to travel to a different state to get an
abortion if it's illegal in your state
now we're starting to see states try to
criminalize that very practice as well
so the reality has been a lot more
draconian than many of us could have
even imagined and if there's any silver
lining at all in the horrors that these
countless women have had to deal with
across the country including in this
story
it's that maybe it will incentivize
people to go out and vote in the fall
maybe democrats will be able to
ultimately hold on to the house of
representatives maybe they'll be able to
pick up a couple of seats in the senate
so that we can move to eliminate the
filibuster and work to codify roe vs
wade into law that has to be the path
forward because we absolutely cannot
trust republicans with control over this
abortion issue and sadly we're probably
going to see plenty more cases like this
one out of florida it's absolutely
sickening